it wasn't just
safety or keeping Kids Safe it was the
appearance of it you know people can
remain ignorant about what their real
risks are
and still have a lot of control over
these things just in in the name of
safety but not real safety Just an
Illusion of it
[Music]
hello everyone I'm speaking today with
Steve Templeton he wrote a recent book
very relevant to the times entitled fear
of a microbial Planet how a germaphobic
safety culture makes us less safe yeah
well it seems to me that a safety
culture All Things Considered probably
makes us globally less safe but that
seems particularly the case uh in
relationship let's say to
germaphobic safety culture given what
happened in the pandemic so what what
what what specifically
motivated you to write this book when
did you start writing it what did you
see happening yeah so first of all thank
you for having me on your show um on
your podcast
um I'm very grateful to be here I've
been a fan since 12 rules for life so um
thanks so much for having me on
um but you know what originally happened
was just with anyone else the pandemic
uh took me by shock to surprise I didn't
uh anticipate how we would respond to
the pandemic and and I didn't anticipate
the appetite of of people for
um being able to have their lives
completely shut down and controlled
um by politicians and other people
Public Health experts so I was really
floored by the the type of response and
the way that people were behaving and it
made me think you know they don't really
have a an idea of their microbial
environment
um because you know you're seeing things
like people wearing masks outside you're
seeing playgrounds being
shut down
hiking trails
things like that that there was
absolutely no evidence that there'd be
any sort of
risk to those activities
and
I was really floored by how widespread
that was you know I mean and people
really bought into it
um you know I saw some a single child at
a playground that was shut down I mean
this was probably a teenager and someone
came up and
and berated him for being on a
playground by themselves when after it
had been shut down so this type of
behavior was really
eye-opening for me it was something that
I didn't expect
and I really started to think why is
this happening I know as as an
immunologist
um
there are going to be pandemics this one
particularly seemed to be age stratified
in terms of mortality children weren't
really affected these were all things
that we were known that no that we knew
very early on
and uh oh so I was really surprised by
that response I started thinking about
um
how to
how to explain it in in a way that
um I could understand so I've kind of
been interested in writing a book and
um this theme sort of kept popping into
my head
of you know all these things that
weren't necessarily controversial
three years ago
um then all of a sudden became
controversial
and uh so that that was kind of the
impetus for for writing the book well
it's interesting because your your
training is an Immunology but what you
said what what you're describing here is
the fact that you're actually struck by
the social and the political response
psychological social and political
response and so I've got a couple of
questions about that the first is
psychologists have started to outline
and and I don't know if this is research
that overlaps with what you study the
operations of what's called uh be often
called sometimes called the behavioral
immune system and I suppose part of the
behavioral immune system is the disgust
response right and it it has a
physiological basis the gag reflex for
example is part of that the fact that
poisons taste bitter to us the fact that
we can be that we sneeze the fact that
disgust will evoke a defensive and
avoidance reaction the fact that we'll
regard things as contaminated those are
all parts of the behavioral immune
response and one way of conceptualizing
what happened with regard to the
pandemic was that it was an you can get
an immune response that goes out of
control like a cytokine storm but this
looked to me like it was the equivalent
of a cytokines storm on the behavioral
immune front and what what does that
does that what do you think of that line
of theorizing does that strike you as
plausible yeah absolutely so for first
of all I've written about
um the connection or at least the
metaphor of an immune response to our
own
pandemic response because in an immune
response things start out pretty
non-specific at first you have a lot of
inflammation you have a lot of tissue
damage but then as as it progresses you
get more of a specific or an Adaptive
response and that is more um you know
antibody cells that are more specific to
Any Given pathogen and there's a lot
less collateral damage because of that
specificity and so
you would you would hope that a pandemic
response would be like that I mean
obviously in the first few weeks you're
not going to know what you're dealing
with
but as the pandemic spread through
different populations you got to see who
the vulnerable people were who wasn't
affected how transmissible it was which
was very highly transmissible
and you would hope the immune the
pandemic response would kind of look
like that like an immune response that
was successful
and defeating a pathogen but I thought
it became more like an autoimmune
response where we started attacking
things that didn't matter like schools
um
and issuing mandates without evidence
that they were really going to make a
difference and so
um I've used that metaphor before in
terms of the behavioral immune response
I think that's it's a really interesting
thing and I've thought about it and
written about it as well
um
because obviously if you're thinking
about the fear
of this being an immunologist I had to
delve into some psychology which is
another reason I'm fascinated to talk to
you about this
but uh you know the the political
um
sort of tribal conflict that we have
here and in the United States seems to
override some of the the studies on
disgust because you would think that
based on studies more people who are
conservative would tend to be more
easily disgusted and that's been done in
studies um and and early on in the
pandemic that was very
um much covered in the Press because um
you know Donald Trump was is a
germaphobe and everyone wanted to kind
of talk about that um media people cover
that a lot
but then it turned out that
um people who are more conservative
tended to reject mandates and and uh
coercive Public Health measures whereas
liberals were more likely to just buy
all into all of it and and enforce it
almost to the level of it you know being
being a religion
and so I think that's really interesting
um that the the sort of political
considerations overrode that that
research well so okay well let's let's
walk down that road for a minute so I
did my lab did some of the research on
discuss sensitivity and conservatism
and we looked at it in relationship for
example to treat conscientiousness
because there's some indication that
conscientious people are more discussed
sensitive
now and and it was striking that as you
pointed out that what you might have
predicted to begin with
um and there there's also a fair bit of
research I can't unfortunately remember
the the the uh researcher's name at the
moment but I had him on my podcast who's
documented quite clearly the
relationship between contamination the
prevalence of contaminants transmissible
contaminants state by state and Country
by country and the probability that
especially right-wing authoritarian
beliefs will arise culturally and and
individually and the relationship is
quite tight
but as you said it looked like it was
the left in particular that was gung-ho
about the
um about the lockdowns even more so than
the conservatives although they were
also complicit now but what seems to
have emerged recently there's there's
another line of psychological research
that bears on this and so
for 70 years
psychologists denied the existence of
left-wing authoritarianism and I'm going
to lay that denial at defeat of social
psychologists because I believe that
they turned a blind eye to left-wing
authoritarianism 100 for political
reasons although it might also be
because some of them were also left-wing
authoritarians but there's been a new
line of research developed and there's
probably only about 10 studies in total
we did one in 2016 before my research
career came to an abrupt and
first of all establishing that left-wing
authoritarianism was identifiable on
statistical grounds but then second
looking at the predictors we found low
verbal intelligence and being female and
having a feminine temperament were solid
predictors of left radical left-wing
beliefs combined with the willingness to
use compulsion and force to enforce them
but more recently people have been
examining the role played by dark tetrad
traits so machiavellianism psychopathy
narcissism and sadism which is an a late
addition to that horrible Triad let's
say
showing I read one Study last week
showing that the relationship between
the dark that malignant narcissism and
left-wing authoritarianism was so strong
that they're almost indistinguishable on
the measurement front and so I wonder if
what we saw wasn't so much a discussed
reaction of the sort that you would
associate with conservatives but an
opportunity for malignant narcissists to
use fear to manipulate the population to
put themselves in positions of power and
like your book you make that case you
know to to Fair degree because you
concentrate not so much on disgust but
on fear and then on well in on on the
machinations that were used by people
who manipulated fear to gain notoriety
and political power in Canada I'll give
you one other example
so in Canada
I know for a fact because I've been told
by the people who were involved even
though they were embarrassed to have
been a part of it that
virtually all the covid lockdown
policies were
implemented on the basis of opinion
polls
and then provided with a post-hoc
justification with the science
right so it was 100 instrumental
manipulation so anyways that's
a set of ideas
yeah I think the it you can reduce it
maybe to instead of left and right
authoritarian versus non-authoritarian
and I think that that's what what you
said is is correct I think the level of
authoritarianism has changed between
left and right in in recent years and
that's because the amount of relative
power I think has changed I mean
um you know and I grew up in the 80s and
I remember
um you know censorship drives and you
know music was being attacked and
everyone was joking about it and
um because conservatives wanted to
censor things and
um you know none of that really happens
anymore it's kind of the other way
around where people can't joke about
certain things and they have to
demonstrate how virtuous they are in
sort of a a left-wing kind of way so I
think that you can reduce it to
um
changes in authoritarianism definitely
yeah well it's still it's still
uncertain
the degree to which let's say we could
make the hypothesis that
over sensitivity to disgust will drive
an authoritarian response on the right
you definitely saw that in the Third
Reich under the Nazis because Hitler for
example appeared to be extremely disgust
sensitive and I read a fair bit of his
spontaneous utterances about the Jews
and all the other people who persecuted
and he used the language of Purity and
contempt and discuss constantly it
wasn't the language of fear I mean he
did you know Foster fear let's say in
relationship to the people he targeted
but more specifically he fostered
disgust and so maybe and no one knows if
this is the case maybe a discussed
reaction that goes overboard Fosters
at least part of right-wing
authoritarianism and the dark tetrad
psychopathy machiavellianism narcissism
and sadism Fosters something like
radical left-wing authoritarianism no
one's cleared that up yet but it seems
it seems at least tentatively plausible
I mean I was struck by the recent
research
in particular because the relationship
between malignant narcissism and
left-wing authoritarianism is
authoritarianism is unbelievably strong
I haven't seen correlations correlations
I think were 0.6 crazily High
correlations for for two constructs that
can't be measured that accurately
so
well so it'd be good it'd be good to
sort that all out as rapidly as we
possibly could uh assuming it would do
some good yeah I agree it's pretty
complicated the use of uh of fear was
very uh going back to what you said a
little bit earlier was definitely
widespread and I think at the beginning
it's it's interesting to look at the the
contrasting messages that were given by
the authorities it in the beginning they
really were trying to prevent panic and
they were really trying to uh lessen the
fear of people because
Studies have shown if you if you are
anticipating in a pandemic is actually
the fear is higher than when it has
actually arrived so
um that many of the messages were
calming and then
uh you know all of a sudden there was
this switch and
um you know once there was Community
spread we knew that there was a lot of
of a virus in around that hadn't wasn't
being detected
um then there it was this sort of
mysterious switch to basically the exact
opposite the sphere-based messaging and
uh yeah so that that was uh really
surprising to me and
and uh and pretty infuriating because I
knew it wasn't going to
to work
yeah well maybe maybe what happened is
that
maybe that reversal took place when the
more narcissistic
Psychopathic power mongerers
started to understand that they could
cement their positions and broaden them
with the use of fear you you mentioned
earlier I thought this was very
interesting you mentioned earlier that
in an immune response that is actually
healthy you get kind of flailing about
on the part of the immune system to
begin with as it attempts to get a
purchase on the virus or the bacteria
and so you get an over generalized
response that's not very specific and
sophisticated but as the system immune
system learns the response gets more and
more targeted more specific and that you
saw the opposite happen in the public
response and that begs the question
right what why what drove the opposite
response like the opposite of learning
and the we want to accrue power to
ourselves narrative and we'll use fear
to do it does seem to
does seem to fit fit the explanatory
Bill let's say yeah that's the that's
the million dollar question is is how
did that happen in my explanation of
thinking about this
um because you know it it happened a lot
in Western countries
um many many Western countries but it
didn't happen everywhere and so
um what I started to think about was
um you know I'm I'm a parent of have a
child that's 11 and one that's seven
they were obviously three years younger
when the pandemic hit but
being a parent of really noticed since I
was a child this sort of emergence of
um
safety is this sort of overriding virtue
of all the the you know taking risks as
being something that's left to Reckless
people
um and you can't even use sort of
probability to assess whether something
is risky or not if it's determined to be
risky then it's hazardous and so I think
the distinctions that used to be
um sort of surrounding
child rearing have in terms of allowing
them to develop on their own and and
take risks and you know get injured if
they make a mistake or you know fail
um you know a lot of that has been uh
removed and I feel like
um this sort of this example really
leads us to the the uh response to the
pandemic I feel like it's it's a
cultural
um problem because if you look at places
that don't have this very strong safety
culture
Nordic countries are a great example
they did not have the same type of
authoritarian response that we did
in in Europe and other Western countries
specifically you know anglo-sphere
countries Canada United States UK
Australia New Zealand
um
they didn't have that and they actually
don't have a
safety culture that's the same I mean I
heard a story when I was in Denmark a
few years ago and
um it's been it was covered widely at
the time about uh parents that went to
New York City and they uh these were
Danish parents they brought their child
in a stroller and they had and in
Denmark it's was very common at the time
to leave their child in a stroller
outside the restaurant so that they
could watch people that you know are
passing by and uh um they got arrested
for doing that in New York City and so
um that was something brought up by my
host in in Denmark was really
interesting that you know they're they
their view of raising children is
different than ours they believe much
more and
um challenging them allowing them to
make their own decisions and so I I
really think that that that explained a
lot and that's how I get to the the
point of having the safety culture in
the title or in the subtitle
is because of of that explanation I mean
anyone who's been
a parent has had to deal or had to deal
with like public schools I mean you know
the threshold for canceling School even
before the pandemic got
and it got pretty low I mean they're
even now they even predict snow in
Indiana here they cancel school it could
never actually snow so
um so these things are much different
than when when I was a kid and I feel
like that has you know as children have
been raised that way and are now adults
now young adults
um I have a feeling that that is is one
way to explain what happened
are you looking for an all-in-one
e-commerce platform that can help you
easily set up and grow your business
online look no further than Shopify with
Shopify you can quickly and easily build
your own online store manage your
inventory and accept payments from
customers plus Shopify offers a range of
customizable themes and templates to
choose from so you can create a
professional looking store without any
design experience it even helps
integrate with other popular tools to
help you sell across social media
marketplaces like Tick Tock Facebook and
Instagram with shopify's 24 7 support
and an extensive Business course library
that is available to support you every
step of the way Shopify is the Commerce
platform revolutionizing millions of
businesses worldwide if you're ready to
get serious about selling try Shopify
today sign up for a one dollar per month
trial period at shopify.com jbp go to
shopify.com jbp to take your business to
the next level today that's shopify.com
jbp
yeah well there is some psychological
research pertaining to that that's
associated with some of the things we've
discussed already which is that mothers
who have clustered B personality
pathology and so that would be
associated with
what's called externalizing behavior in
women it's borderline personality
disorder for example are much less
likely to Foster Independence in their
children
and so and that cluster B is also
associated with some of the dark tetrad
traits that we discussed that malignant
narcissism that
psychopathy machiavellianism
sadism you know perhaps is pushing it
but perhaps not
because
the the question of course is why does
that safety culture emerge and you can
attribute some of that to neuroticism to
fear but you can also attribute it to
the willingness of hyperprotective
parents to use
their
purported concern for the security of
their children to justify their use of
excessive power and control
you know and this is part of the reason
why your book and the title of your book
is is interesting and the attack you're
taking on this right because you are
looking at the Nexus between the use of
fear and the justification for power and
the safety culture it's got that virtue
signaling element right which which is
extremely dangerous it's like well
listen dear the reason I'm doing this
for you is because I care so much about
you and all I really care is about your
let's say short-term security and it's
hard to argue against that because of
course safety is a Paramount concern or
an important concern when you're dealing
with children but the problem is that it
can be gamed by people who want to exert
power and who can use their putative
moral superiority as a justification and
I do think this this is this is a kind
of epidemic I guess a question I would
have for you too is like
I'm increasingly bothered by the fact
that we even refer to a pandemic
you know Jay about a chariot no ionides
ionides who's a very good uh
statistician and and researcher uh I
mean he was the person who initiated the
so-called replication crisis in
Psychology showing that so much of
psychological research actually didn't
replicate not that it's necessarily
worse than other disciplines but he just
published a paper or has published
papers showing that the the case
fatality rate for covid is way lower
than we had been led to believe in fact
it's so low I think that you could argue
that there wasn't a pandemic at all in
some real sense and you see this echoed
in the Swedish data because if you I
believe if you average out the death
rate over a two-year period there's no
statistical blip in deaths in Sweden
during the so-called covid years and so
I think our terminology for what
happened during that time might also be
deeply wrong and that what we had was an
we had an epidemic of tyrannical
lockdown
with a with a putative novel illness
while the illness was novel but a
putative pandemic as the as the excuse
now maybe that's too radical but I'm not
sure it is too radical you know it
certainly was a disease that I think the
Israel the Israelis recently announced
if I remember correctly that they didn't
have any deaths at all
for people under 50 who had fewer than
four comorbidities
something like that and so like do you
think it's completely Preposterous to
Proclaim that we didn't have a pandemic
at all
except one of tyranny yeah
I would say we had a pandemic but
um
uh you know the the response was
was something that we really uh really
blew and didn't you know focus on the
people who were actually affected I mean
if you have a population of people who
are average of 81 of people who are
dying that's going to be actually pretty
difficult to measure in terms of you
know excess deaths and because a lot of
people in that age group and with
comorbidities if you have a pandemic
that lasts two years the chances of many
of those folks living two years is is
much lower than it is in populations of
say young people so
um the ability to measure that becomes
more difficult when you're dealing with
an old and or frail or infirm population
I think well that's especially true too
if you if you then purposefully confuse
dying with covid with dying from covid
which clearly happened right and I mean
I talked to Physicians who said that
they were instructed by their well their
professional organizations
they were encouraged by their
professional organizations to list any
death with covid as a death from covid
and God only knows how that
gerrymandered the statistics and I think
it was the London times even the times
now
um reported two days ago on the fact
that all the evidence in the UK suggests
that the costs to the lockdown were
orders of magnitude above the costs that
were actually associated with the
biological pathogen itself
right they're not even in the same
league it's not like the lockdowns were
a little worse than the virus they were
stunningly worse than the virus and and
we haven't even seen all the accruing
catastrophe that's emerged from that yet
I mean I don't know what to make of the
excess death statistics for example that
that just don't seem to go away do you
have any thoughts on that matter meaning
you know in the last few years we have
more access deaths yeah yeah yeah well
well even even right now it doesn't like
right the the excess deaths in Europe
are between 15 and 20 percent something
like that 10 and 20 percent above normal
and that doesn't seem to be going away
right you know I think the simplest
explanation for that is that we hurt
people very badly with the lockdowns but
then the the other open question is
is there some degree to which the actual
vaccines are contributing to this and
you know that's an absolutely horrifying
possibility but I don't think it's off
the table statistically at the moment
yeah I mean the the the vaccines were
very promising for people who were in
that vulnerable age group but uh you
know what happened was uh politics took
over especially here and mandates in
addition to removing all liability from
the vaccines themselves which had been
tested minimally and not necessarily on
the population you'd want to test them
on that is older and infirm people
um they were minimally tested and so you
know for an emergency you'd want to
focus on the vulnerable population
because that would wear the biggest
benefit would uh would be obvious but
that didn't happen
um I believe that there was a lot of
influence from pharmaceutical companies
um acting upon government agencies and
their incentives were actually not to
promote actual public health of people
here in the United States and I'm sure
in the UK and Canada it was exactly the
same there was outside influences the
same is true for you know just counting
covet deaths if you provide an incentive
to over count if you give hospitals more
money for coveted patients um
whether they're and if they're on a
ventilator or their type of treatment
you're providing an incentive for those
um hospitals and health care providers
to increase those numbers so that they
can increase their profits and these are
just it's just a matter of incentives
giving people perverse incentives is
going to lead to perverse outcomes and
uh and I think that's exactly what
happened
when you
started writing this book when you
started observing the what was happening
around you how would you characterize
your political stance because people are
who are listening are going to be
wondering and and I think it's a
reasonable thing to wonder
what how your a priori political stance
might have formed the lens through which
you were viewing what was laying itself
out how would how would you have
characterized your political views let's
say five years ago and how would you
characterize them now
I've always been a uh you know I've been
in Academia for a long time I wasn't you
know graduate school for a while and
here in Indiana for about 12 years so
um being around other scientists being
around other people in universities and
medical schools I was never you know the
the most I was not a liberal person in
in
um relation to my peers in that way
um if you put me in a room of um people
who are hardcore you know Trump
supporters I wouldn't fit in with that
that group either so
um you know I haven't actually
you know voted for someone who's won an
election in a very long time so if that
gives you an idea
um I I would probably say I was a center
right but one of the things that this
really became associated with anyone
who's willing to speak up
it uh there was this fear that you'd be
automatically put into this Camp of you
know well you're doing this for
political reasons you're doing this
because you support Trump or something
like that and I really encountered that
both from
friends and acquaintances that were and
even people just on social media that I
didn't know but uh you know that were
liberal they would assume that I was you
know
hardcore right-wing Trump supporter and
even Trump supporters would assume that
which um you know when it comes to
closing schools this became so
politicized that even wanting hope to
open schools became a sign that you know
you didn't want to necessarily agree
with Trump on something and uh and that
was that was really unfortunate I heard
this firsthand from
people that I talk to it's not something
that I I anticipated really at all
because I've lived in a world where a
lot of people I know and like uh you
know disagree with me
um my wife and I disagree on a lot of
things and uh and I'm used to that but
this is kind of the world where that
we're in now where that's not
those kind of disagreements are are not
allowed and discussion and debate are
shut down
yeah well the question I guess one of
the questions that we might want to
address today is what do we think we
could do to make sure that the next time
this happens assuming there is a next
time we're not quite so insane about it
and I would say also what could we learn
so that we don't respond the same way to
other hypothetical crises that confront
us because I feel that we could do
precisely the same thing and that there
are many people hoping this will happen
in some real sense that we could do
exactly the same thing for example on
the climate Doom front and you know the
more paranoid conspiratorial types of
have presumed that this was just a
warm-up for that but I have a certain
degree of sympathy for their concerns
given what happened now you start your
book out part one of your book is fear
and germs and one of the things you do
to begin with is to lay out a little bit
of background for people about the
nature of the microbial environment that
we do find ourselves in right so that
you can I suppose you can give people
some sense of
how much the relative risk increased
because of the introduction of this new
pathogen do you want to walk us through
that a bit Yeah so I use my uh my oldest
sister as an example of a of a
germaphobe because she was a nurse in a
cardiac surgical team and you know
obviously her job was very much involved
being very diligent about preventing
infections and patients and so I think
that sort of translated into you know
she brought that home and became very
diligent about avoiding infections and
sanitizing and you know any sort of
exposure to germs she became sort of
interested in
um and obsessed with
um
dealing with and so I use her as an
example and I talk about how
um you know that that way of thinking is
not
not helpful because we're in we're
already in a microbial world and we're
exposed
to all sorts of things we have you know
at least 10 viruses latently infected in
her system in her body at any given time
possibly more and that's not counting
viruses that infect the bacteria that
inhabit us which are
um astronomically High numbers so I kind
of lay out just how much
exposure we have
to microbes that we don't realize
um and uh you know what it's just
everywhere in the environment and it's
not something you can avoid
and then I talk about you know although
that's the case there are definitely
instances where we've become very clean
and our ability to avoid microbial
exposures has resulted in some first
world diseases like increased
autoimmunity increased allergy
asthma those type of things these are
all first world diseases you don't see
them in developing countries nearly the
same prevalence that you see
here and in Canada and UK and other
places
so I talk about why that is and mainly
it's because we're not exposed to the
same level of
um
environmental microbes even pathogens
that we used to be because of obviously
huge gains that we had from sanitation
Revolution we don't want to go back to
that but something has definitely been
lost and you know I give many examples
of of that you know in terms of
pandemics polio is an example where
polio
was endemic for a very long time
until sanitation approved improved to
the point where people weren't being
exposed to polio until they were older
and then it became a lot more severe and
noticeable in you know when you're
talking about older children as opposed
to a baby who's nursing who just has a
mild infection and their mother
breastfeeds and helps them clear the
virus so
um you know that was an example of a
trade-off and so I wanted to sort of
highlight that all of these things were
trade-offs and you know people have been
this hasn't been controversial
um at all for a long time
whether you're feeling stressed anxious
or simply seeking a moment of peace and
Tranquility the Hallow app has something
for you hallo offers an incredible range
of guided meditations and prayers that
are designed to help you deepen your
spirituality and strengthen your
connection to God with hallow you can
explore different themes and types of
prayer and meditation such as gratitude
forgiveness and centering prayer you can
also choose from different lengths of
meditation to fit your schedule whether
you have a few minutes or an hour with
this user-friendly interface and
hundreds of guided meditations the
Hallow app has quickly become a go-to
resource for people seeking spiritual
growth and healing download the app for
free at hallow.com Jordan you can set
prayer reminders and track your progress
along the way hallow is truly
transformative and will help you connect
with your faith on a deeper level so
what are you waiting for download the
Hallow app today at hallow.com Jordan
that's hello.com Jordan once again it's
hello.com Jordan for an exclusive
three-month free trial of all six
thousand plus prayers and meditations
there's no reason to aim for something
like zero microbial exposure because
that's completely Preposterous and so I
think if I remember correctly in terms
of sheer cell number I think you have
more bacteria in your body than cells
now they happen to be very very tiny but
it gives you some that gives the
listeners and Watchers let's say some
indication of just exactly how prevalent
as you said the microbial load is and
then do you have any sense of what
actually constitutes let's say
reasonable precautions you don't want to
sterilize everything in sight partly
because maybe you make your immune
system hyper responsive if you're
overprotected but obviously we don't
want to return to the filth of the the
centuries prior to the 20th century
where well where people were dying of
infectious diseases at an incredible
rate especially in hospitals let's say
so what and I I don't imagine you made
yourself particularly popular with your
older sister by the way
um using her as an example but but um so
what what do you what do you think of as
a reasonable response to you know to to
cleanliness given the necessity of
minimizing both kind of error yeah so
um you know certain
viruses
are pretty nasty and cause really awful
infections in in people but it turns out
that in a general sense the the nastier
the the virus the harder it is is to
transmit it and so there's sort of a an
association between the ability to
transmit something and then the severity
of the disease that it it transmits and
so if you take something like
HIV it's a nasty
um infection has a very long
period where there's not a lot of
symptoms but then
um becomes very awful in terms of
destruction of the immune system leading
to opportunistic infections however you
can avoid getting HIV for the most part
unless you have some sort of accidental
exposure directly to your blood which
does which did happen but has been
you know greatly reduced
same thing is true about something like
hepatitis um you know these are nasty
infections but you don't necessarily get
um them from just being in contact with
other people
in terms of respiratory infections those
are much more harder to avoid because
they are
very easily transmissible they have a
lot of genetic for variability
um and so the immune system is able to
might be able to prevent severe disease
but not the actual infection itself so
you know there are some
viruses that you want to avoid and some
that you really can't
um and and people should kind of
understand the distinction between that
yeah well the rationale was uh
I think once that became obvious that
the rationale was well if we slowed the
rate at which it spread we wouldn't
overwhelm the hospital systems and you
know one of the things I saw in Canada
that was particularly
remarkably uh dim and pathological was
that
the governments took almost no actions
whatsoever to increase the availability
of emergency of intensive care unit uh
in intensive care units which was seemed
at least at the time and maybe you can
correct me if I'm wrong seemed like the
logical thing to do especially after
this extended over a multi-year period I
mean we knew how early did we know that
virtually everybody was going to get
covet you said as as you pointed out
respiratory illnesses are transmissible
and there isn't really a damn thing you
can do about it yeah I mean the
the response was was much very much like
you know a behavioral modification was
absolutely necessary and everyone had to
completely change their behavior
um and then and that sort of did not
consider the the length of time that was
going to be necessary and the fact that
you know the whole world doesn't operate
that way we're so interconnected
um you know you'd read articles about
how I would read them and think you know
people would talk about yeah just get
groceries delivered and
um you know you don't have to leave your
house and but somebody somewhere is
going to have to leave their house in
order to support that
and uh these things weren't really
thought out
and uh you know as a result
um in some cases it could be delayed but
not completely
eliminated by behavioral modifications
yeah well wouldn't you say they're not
completely thought out I mean I I think
that's what you might say that's the
understatement of the decade I I watched
recently a viral video of the new CDC
director talking about how she made the
decision to lock down football
and she is giggling while she's saying
this which is appalling Beyond
Comprehension and it doesn't really seem
to me to be a nervous giggle it's more
like well isn't this cute it's so funny
that this is the way it happened she
talks about talking to one of the health
officials in Massachusetts and just sort
of bandying back and forth ideas about
who should be locked down next in this
case it was anybody who wanted to go
watch football game and that kind of
random scatter shot approach to
depriving people of their civil
liberties seem to be par for the course
and with this particular video is an
incredibly egregious example of that
because it combines an idiot cutesiness
with this terrible proclivity to well to
really deprive people of their
fundamental Mobility rights you know
except for the Expendable people let's
say who were doing the grocery
deliveries and there was a really nasty
element to that as well is that you know
the important people could stay at home
and lock them so ourselves up and
protect themselves but the Expendable
working class could go about their
business as usual right I mean there are
all sorts of of exceptions too right so
I mean if they're either lots of videos
of
um you know where I don't know what the
the video version of a hot mic is but
we're you know
um officials would know that they were
off camera or think that they were off
camera and you could see them
immediately take their masks off you
know because
um they're truly believing that this is
something they have to perform to show
for people and they don't necessarily
believe
that it's it's going to be 100 effective
um in in reality and so there were lots
of of examples of that where people
didn't actually believe
um what they were saying I mean when
there were protests
um there were there were lots of Public
Health people that said you know
protesting racism is public health
necessity or something like that and a
lot of a lot of people rightfully
identified that as as just being
completely
a bit but based on nonsense I mean
um the idea that you know the same thing
happened with cop 26 in in the UK right
so it wasn't just like black lives
matter protests it was also climate
change meetings the the UK government
completely inverted its rules to allow
the delegates to the climate change uh
conference to proceed a pace with no
restrictions because apparently that was
what the important people got to do
whereas ordinary people who were going
about their lives weren't able to
continue and one of the things we did
see and and this is going to have
extraordinary long-term consequences is
that there was a massive transfer of
wealth from the like essentially working
class and lower middle class business
owners who got demolished by the
pandemic restrictions to huge retailers
like Amazon and once those little
businesses are gone
and many of them disappeared it's very
hard to get them back and so
and I don't know you know I don't know
how you count up that kind of collateral
damage when you're trying to derive the
statistics about exactly what the
pandemic lockdowns cost us because the
toll that took on families well there's
no one even interested in measuring that
I suppose in some fundamental sense
yeah I mean you cannot put a single
number on it because there's so many
areas of life
that are affected by it I mean Health
Care in a way of treatment of cancer
treatment of heart attacks screenings
the kind of diagnostic tests all of
these things were completely eliminated
people who were dependent on communities
um
Alcoholics Anonymous that kind of thing
all those things were shut down
um
and some people needed that to survive
and were unable to to continue something
that would that kept them in a healthier
State than they would be otherwise and
so this sort of singular coveted
monomania was is so damaging in so many
areas and you know you see it
every day there's some some news that
comes out you know the kids you know BMI
has doubled you know and uh
um retention rates are still low in
terms of kids staying in school even you
know three years after the pandemic and
uh test scores right right and a huge
number of kids never
a huge number of kids never returned to
school
yeah absolutely and so
um you know there's studies that have
shown that even three months of
disruption in a child's education can
affect their uh long-term you know
ability to uh um earn money and make a
living and you know to have this happen
on kind of a global scale people who are
already in in a poverty type situation
are going to be forced further into that
into that than they would be otherwise
and so it's going to be so pervasive
that it's going to be very difficult to
to measure but we're seeing so much of
it in terms of of other health care
costs
um inflation all that stuff this is all
very related to to what happened
look there's an intro another
interesting political issue here too
that's I guess relevant to the use of
fear and also to some of the topics we
discussed earlier so one of the things I
found
that was virtually miraculous in terms
of its incomprehensibility was the fact
that people particularly on the left
lined up on the side of the
pharmaceutical companies and if if you
would have told me 10 years that 10
years ago that left-wing
politicos and believers
would have aligned themselves with
pharmaceutical companies I would have
thought you were completely out of your
mind because the bug bearer of the left
the bugbearers of the left on the
corporate front for the last 60 years
likely have been oil companies and
pharmaceutical companies you know and
with some justification especially in
the latter category and yet
there was this Unholy alliance between
the left-wing authoritarians and the
pharmaceutical companies and I can't
help but think that that's likely
mediated by this
Association heretofore un unexamined
association between psychopathy
narcissism machiavellianism sadism and
the desire for power because one of the
things that aligning with the
pharmaceutical companies did for the
power mongering left was
um what would you say justify their
their willingness to use power to compel
and force people and I can't find
another explanation because it's so it
runs so counter to what you would assume
the leftist narrative would be because
the of all the people who should be
skeptical of gigantic pharmaceutical
corporations you think the leftists
would be number one
so I don't know if you've had any
thoughts about that yeah absolutely you
would think that
um you know with the sort of natural
distrust of big business and
pharmaceutical companies that has
historically been on the left
um combined that with the distrusts of
um the ability of government
on the right to to take over uh massive
projects
um
subsidized economies take you know
regulate all health care and things like
that
you think that there would be some
bipartisan consensus there but that
wasn't the case at all
um and I think you know for certain
people
um this this benefited them
um to
sort of push
the uh this they they shared the same
entrance interests with pharmaceutical
companies
um and people who were were in power and
even if that didn't
mesh with their political beliefs in the
past the the promise of gaining power
and influence was simply you know too
much to
it it basically overrode that that
traditional stance so so in the first
part of your book you
a bit about
germs and and you try to make a case
for what the proper relationship might
be between a fair response and the say
the overwhelming prevalence of of the
microbial uh biome around us in the
second part of your book you concentrate
more on a pandemic in the time of safety
so maybe we should delve into that a
little bit more I don't feel that you've
you've had the opportunity to develop
your hypothesis about the relationship
between the safety culture and the
planning and pandemic planning
thoroughly do you want you one of your
chapters six is pandemic planning meets
the safety culture seven is all the Doom
we need and the face Badge of virtue do
you want to delve into that a little bit
more and elaborate that for the for
everybody who's watching and listening
right yeah so the first part of that is
sort of the realization that
um you know the safety culture is is
enabled
um a lot of this this to happen a lot of
people like to you know describe the
whole pandemic response and all the bad
things that happened to you know a
select few you know super villains out
there and while I am sure that lots of
people took advantage of the situation
in sort of odious ways
um I didn't feel like
um that's just not my nature to
to think in the sort of conspiratorial
terms and blame a small you know cabal
of of uh super villains on on the whole
pandemic response
um but instead
I feel like there was a cultural problem
that enabled all of this and I I could
see it in some of the things even on a
local level one example I give is um
when when my daughter was probably about
two years old she uh got what's called
hand foot and mouth disease and her
daycare her take in a hand foot mouth
disease is one of these things where
if it gets into like a daycare it's not
gonna get out until everybody gets it
and gets over it and who's susceptible
at least and adults daycare workers can
get it and have very
mild or no symptoms and still be able to
transmit it um to others it's passed
through the stool and so if you're at a
daycare and you've got Toddlers and
babies it's nearly impossible to keep
that cleaning to prevent spread once
it's there it's going to spread and but
it's very um sort of innocuous this
gives children it makes them very
uncomfortable they can't eat they have
sores in their mouth
um they have sores in their body they
have a fever for a few days but then it
goes away
and sometimes it takes a while for you
know the spots on their body to heal and
what the daycare was telling us is that
my daughter had to stay home until she
was completely healed which
um was opposite of what you know had
been people had been told about hand
foot and mouth disease for a very long
time it was generally you know what the
American Academy of Pediatrics said was
that after they've had fever a day later
they can go back to school or daycare or
whatever
but instead we were we were told to be
um
you know to keep our kid home and you
know continue to pay for daycare and
um until her all of her lesions were
completely healed
and uh you know that wouldn't have made
anyone safer I mean this
um was that obviously she got the virus
at the daycare which means it was in the
daycare it was going to be spread lots
of kids were going to get it
um and and it's just going to blow
through the daycare and until it was
done
um and so keeping her home would have
been absolutely had zero
uh effect on the spread in the daycare
but at the same time
the local Health Department
um backed up
what the uh the daycare owner said
um and and said that she should she
should stay home for two weeks even
though our pediatrician
agreed with us based on what the
American Academy of Pediatrics said so I
mean I went directly to the health
department and talked to the the head of
the health department and you know she
was basically Unapologetic and I really
thought
um later I really thought later on that
you know this this way of thinking
um
could be translated into how we thought
about the pandemic response and it
wasn't just
safety or keeping Kids Safe it was the
appearance of it that was important and
so I have a
um a chapter called hurting children for
the appearance of safety and that's you
know one of the things that that really
bothered me as a parent not just an
immunologist or infectious disease
scientist
um the ability of uh you know people can
remain ignorant about what their real
risks are
and still have a lot of control about
um over these things just in the in the
name of
safety but not real safety Just an
Illusion of it it seems to me that you
know your chapter nine hurting children
for the appearance of safety for the
appearance of safety part of the
question there is well why would people
be concerned about the appearance of
safety and I think part of the reason
for that is that
people like to use their concern for
children and for other vulnerable people
let's say as a way of signaling just
exactly how morally virtuous they are
it's it's a real demonstrative
performance of look how much I care
and it also gives you the opportunity if
you do that not only to elevate your
moral virtue as a consequence of doing
that in an unearned way but to demonize
anybody that would stand in the way
which is also convenient if what you're
trying to do is to accrue power you know
you told the story about your daycare
when when you were
in the midst of that
was was your what was your personal
reaction I mean how did you how did you
find yourself responding to the demands
that the daycare was making on you and
your wife your family
yeah given that you knew that their
actual factual concerns were unwarranted
yeah well I would think that you know I
had some sort of relevant knowledge
um that could affect
um the outcome of this it actually
helped other parents because
um you know this was obviously going to
come up other kids were going to get the
infection because it's highly contagious
um and kids can transmit it for weeks
after their symptoms have resolved so um
even when
you know the spots had completely healed
she could still give it to other kids
and so
um I wanted the other parents to
understand
that this had really no basis
in in in making their kids safer there
was no argument that could be made and I
would think that that would have had an
effect
on the the owner of the daycare didn't
at all
um in fact we ended up
getting booted from that daycare but
um
that experience that experience
was uh I think you know really set up it
helps set up the the pandemic response
because there's something has changed in
the culture where
um we don't accept any sort of risk we
want we want risk to be completely
minimized away until there's none which
is many cases not possible
and if that isn't possible then we want
to pretend that we can do that and uh
and the illusion of of control the
illusion of being able to to eliminate
any sort of risk
um it becomes very attractive uh for
people and and any sort of leader or
official politician
whatever it becomes a very easy sell
when people are afraid
and uh and that's kind of the way that I
that I said set up all this safety
culture
explanation for how we responded
interestingly to me that you and your
child got the boot from that particular
daycare and so you know that that perked
up my clinical years let's say because
that seems to me to be a perfectly
logical extension of exactly what
happened if we're using the power
mongering Theory here a bit what what
happened exactly there and and what did
that what what what did you what did you
derive from that what moral did you
derive from that yeah I mean I uh I
basically contacted all the other
parents
um in an email chain and told them why
this was not
um
making any of their children safer
and uh you know the none of them really
responded saying you know thank you or
anything like that it was more the
daycare owner saying you know you don't
have a right to do that and
um we don't want you to come back after
your daughter is better so
um on what crowns what grounds exactly
well I mean that was kind of a a
personality thing too
um that uh that we had we had discovered
before with other
other issues so
um I don't think that's necessarily a
cultural thing however I do think what
the the health department did and the
way that they responded agreeing with
the daycare order they would have no
other reason
to
um support her other than the fact that
they've sort of been conditioned to be
over cautious and in ways that wouldn't
actually make people safer and that was
uh you know ultimately how I made that
connection once people started behaving
in a way treating children like they
were disease vectors I mean the way that
my kids were treated at school even in a
place like Indiana which you wouldn't
think would be you know like Portland OR
San Francisco
the way that they were treated even even
in the public schools in my area
was just completely unnecessary and not
based on evidence
at all and so
my futility
of dealing with the the daycare
situation
was kind of a harbinger of my futility
to deal with anything in the uh local
area in terms of trying to quell Panic
or irrational or non-evidence-based
responses and the way the children were
treated more specifically
so let me throw out a couple of
hypotheses that you with regards to the
prevalence of this
this so
here's five different reasons perhaps
why it's become more prevalent
so one would be
people have children much later than
they used to
so instead of having children in their
early 20s they have their children in
their early 30s and so that means that
in some ways their grandparents by the
time they have children rather than the
normal age for human beings to have
children and I suspect that makes them
less risk tolerant
because younger people are Wilder and
more impulsive and obviously there's a
downside to that but God only knows what
the upside is then the next problem
hypothetically might be that well you
know if you have
six kids
you're just not going to be able to
exercise that much control over them
because they outnumber you terribly and
you're exhausted and you're gonna just
let the tribe go out and do like tribal
things and you're going to chase them
the hell out of the house because you
know enough kids but if you have one
well then you have all your eggs in one
basket so to speak and so
and the child is also not being
challenged and provoked by his or her
siblings in that constant manner that
might have been the case more likely it
when there were more siblings and then
also parents are richer now
and so that means that they can dote in
a way that would have been practically
impossible before and then additionally
like we did find for example in the
study that I cited to you at the
beginning of our discussion that one of
the predictors of left-wing
authoritarianism was being female and
also having a female temperament it was
quite a strong predictor and quite a
surprising predictor and there are a lot
more female dominated families and
institutions now than there were 40
years ago I mean there's lots of single
mother families and then in schools of
course the vast preponderance of
teachers are female and so
well there's five reasons why the safety
culture might have become increasingly
Paramount
so I I don't know if you have you have
you thought through at all and and and
and and
written about
why you think that culture has become
more predominant I mean we obviously
have talked about its dangers yeah
well to think about some of the things
that you've said
um with the size of families I mean in
the age that people are having children
um that certainly might have something
to do with it if you look at places like
where I live
um so in in the United States there are
a lot of different areas where the
average age that someone a family desire
decides to have children is different
here it's probably much lower and I know
it's much lower than it is on the coast
and so there are lots of families here
where
um
you know
they're having three kids by the time
they're the mother is 28 or something
like that I mean that's something that
you wouldn't see uh generally
on a major population Cosmopolitan City
on the coast
and so you would see differences if that
were the main explanation you would see
differences in safety culture and you
see some of that but I mean like in the
neighborhood I live in there's a whole
it's a it's like a historic neighborhood
there's a whole degree of socioeconomic
levels in the neighborhood and there's
just it's it's very difficult to find
lots of children outside playing
um and even even with those those levels
there and I think that
um so I think it that's that's one
possible contributing factor but
um it's not
uh it can't be the whole the whole
explanation because even here you know I
try to get my kids to go outside but
um they don't want to because there
isn't an outdoor culture like there used
to be I mean I knew I would miss
something I knew I was going to miss
something if I didn't go outside
um and they will miss something if they
go outside because you know there's
computers and there's
um you know streaming and you know
there's a whole lot of Alternatives that
can keep them inside so I think that's
another part of it is that you know
before there wasn't any there wasn't any
mechanism
any sort of alluded to that a little bit
in terms of being wealthy
um to to dote on children to be
helicopter parents
um the tools to do that have become
um much more available
and uh and so I think that's another
possibilities and that you know goes to
the whole the whole explanation of you
know in
there's still this debate out there did
Zoom
um enable the pandemic
um
response that we had and I think that I
think there's a lot there's a lot to
that the technology became
um matched what the culture wanted to do
and uh it basically took it in that
direction whereas it wasn't wouldn't
have been possible
so Steve you experienced on a broader
scale in the social world the same thing
or something analogous to what happened
to you at your local daycare and you
learned something about the opaqueness
let's say of the general population or
maybe even of the human mind to to
scientific research
I mean whatever we might be as human
beings we're not it's not easy to make
us into scientists and so what did you
learn on that front
yeah so it seemed to me like people
really wanted to be
um
given certainty
in things that were not necessarily
certain or fully known and they don't
want to
um leave things up to chance and like I
said they want risks reduced
to
to zero which in any case can't can't be
done I'd see this with you know the the
local schools sometimes
um
my children would come home and tell me
you know even things that weren't
mandated
by the school they were doing extra
taking extra measures you know they were
like dousing them with hand sanitizer
um you know hand sanitizer is not
something that's
um proven to be effective on um
especially for Respiratory viruses it
doesn't even actually work that well for
other types of viruses like GI viruses
which you would want it to be more
effective for that than hand washing
so I mean all these measures they
another thing they they made them do was
they could not play with each other
unless they were in the same class so
even when they were outside at recess
they had to distance themselves from the
other classes so if my my daughter had
friends in another class they couldn't
interact with each other and um you know
outside for how long for how long was
that for how long was that policy in
place yeah probably a a whole year
um and so I I was I was asked at some
point to be on
a um Advisory board for the local school
district and I think one of the reasons
I was asked is because I had talked to
the medical director of our County
Health Department and had become kind of
friendly with him and even though we
disagreed with some things on
um in public
you know there wasn't as much
disagreement and we were you know still
became
I'm fairly friendly with one another
discussing things that were happening
but uh he recommended to the
superintendent that I'd be on this board
because a lot of the people other people
were local Physicians and Community
people who would never really
deviate from what they were being told
by the CDC and other organizations and
so they actually did want somebody who
was contrarian to kind of
challenge what was
what was being mandated and what was
being done in the schools so that was a
pretty good opportunity although you
know you really encounter the
cautiousness
of people especially Physicians you know
I mean they are used to being avoiding
caution and being very cautious and
avoiding any sort of risk in their
practices because they're afraid of
malpractice and you know they've been
sort of conditioned to think that way
um and so um it was kind of a tall order
to be able to convince them that a lot
of these measures were hurting children
not actually
um
making them safer and we're really only
there in sort of a theatrical way
um to to give people this sort of
Illusion or appearance of safety
and I started writing I had been writing
for the local paper
um some on some of these issues about
especially how children were treated and
um
obviously those weren't going over well
um but then some of the writing started
to get picked up on a national level
and one of the reasons is you know I
started really putting together
um evidence and compiling it for things
like masks especially in in a child
population which there was really no
evidence that they would make a
difference in schools and there was no
consensus prior to the pandemic that
they would play an important role in
pandemic mitigation you could go back
and read papers for 10 years before
and uh and really see that just by just
by looking at the the the Publications
even up until you know the beginning of
the pandemic there was really no
consensus about whether masks would work
for the population much less for
children so I put together a lot of
evidence and gave some presentations to
the uh the Physicians and the other
people
and um you know I think it had an effect
but in the end the governor sort of
overrode
all of the local districts power
because you know they had mandates for
masks tied to things like
um you know the ability of classrooms to
operate with you know six feet of
separation between children which was
impossible and then
um if they were masked they would have
and arbitrary completely arbitrary
um if they were if they were masked then
they could have three feet which is
actually doable
so um
six feet was was something that schools
didn't have the space to do and so that
was essentially a mask mandate without
actually calling it a mass mandate but
anyway because I put together these
things it really became useful to write
about them and and uh and and it ended
up getting some some national
attention getting picked up by certain
Outlets like Brownstone Institute and
other outlets that a lot of people read
and so that's how I kind of got
from the local level to a little bit
more a national
um exposure and uh you know ultimately
to the point where
I had enough to to write a book
when did your book come out
yeah it came out in April so it's been
out less than less than two months
doing it got a really good push and one
of the reasons is because I have a lot
of I've made a lot of friends
um you know uh Jay bhattacharya talked
with you about this you know the
prevalence of social media is is a curse
and a
um
a blessing because it could really put
people together that would normally not
be able to Define each other and so I've
met a lot of people through social media
and through my writing
um that has really sort of formed a
community and given me a lot of other
opportunities
um I was involved in you know writing a
document that you talked about with Jay
which we call the Norfolk group document
um I uh questions for covid-19
commission that is being used by people
in Congress
um I was invited to be on a public
health Integrity committee for Florida
appointed by the governor DeSantis and
the Surgeon General
so because of all these connections
um you know when I when I released the
book I could ask a lot of people to
retweet it and you know
write a little bit about it and so I
have a lot of connections that way so I
think that really translated into a
pretty nice push at the beginning
um obviously doing things like being on
your podcast will help tremendously as
well so I haven't got the sales numbers
yet but I think it's I think it's doing
okay
so so there's some optimism in
scribed I mean you you you have
attempted to
voice our
a contrarian opinion let's say although
one that increasingly appears to be in
accordance with
anything with with with with common
sense and with the facts on the ground I
think that's got to the point now where
that's indisputable unless you're
completely off Off Your Rocker so that's
a positive thing and and here's another
mystery you know
I I I I think that what we did during
the pandemic was Unforgivable
however we did stop doing it
and it isn't exactly clear to me why you
know given everything we've talked about
given the joy that people had like my
sense in Canada especially in Toronto
which is my home city was that
70 percent of people who lived in
Toronto would have been perfectly happy
they would have worn a mask for the rest
of their lives without making a peep and
half of them would have been happy about
it just because it would have given them
an opportunity to inform and spy on
their neighbors and it was pretty
appalling to see but you know in the
final analysis
we did back down right we backed off
this and we have lifted the
pandemic restrictions and requirements
and we have returned to something
approximating whatever the hell The New
Normal is right I mean things are a lot
less bizarre than they were during the
lockdown and like why do you think it is
that we move back from the brink given
all the push there was to put us in this
authoritarian position to begin with
well that's a really good question I
mean I think all of the
the Machinery of the pandemic response
and is still there
um I think
you have to have
a leadership class that has learned a
lesson
from what happened and I'm not really
sure that that's that's the case
because you can see it you know there
are some areas where they there is some
concession of harms of the pandemic
response you know you see people running
away from the idea that we should have
closed schools even to the point of
pretending that they never advocated for
it
such as like Randy Weingarten of the
American Federation of teachers
um you know you see that happening it's
sort of a tacited mission that there are
certain things that people will actually
understand were very very harmful
but at the same time it's still not
enough
to have that sort of underlying
admission there has to be a real
accounting
of what happened and and why it happened
and I think you know some of that's
happening on the political level with
coveted commissions and U.S Congress and
other
other countries but it's going to be
kind of a long haul because there's a
lot of people who will want to sort of
control how the history is told in a way
that
um kind of whitewashes the the harms of
of what was done
so
has the fact that we did Retreat from
the authoritarian controls that were
implemented has that restored a certain
degree of optimism to you it doesn't
exactly sound like it I mean the
argument that you just made
seems to be if I've got this right that
you think that
it wouldn't take a lot of provocation
for the same kind of hammers to come
down again but that does beg the
question why why do you think it why do
you think it was lifted
I mean we we kind of made an arbitrary
decision in some ways that the pandemic
was over and I don't understand why we
reverted back to something approximating
normality well I mean was it finally
that enough people got got tired of it
people like Jay bhattacharya and and
started to make enough noise so that
there was some pushback it just took
people a while to get organized it was
because enough people got infected is
what I think
um you know you have these really highly
transmissible variants like Omicron that
were actually quite um not as severe as
their you know not as severe as the
earlier variants and they just spread
like wildfire and I mean it's been shown
that if you're on the edge of a pandemic
and you haven't experienced it your
anxiety and fear levels are much much
higher in the population because they're
getting their information from the news
and they're getting their information
from the media in a way that's not
comforting because the media relies on
advertisements and clicks and things
like that so the fear level when you're
not exposed to the actual pathogen is
quite high but then once it's once it's
actually burned through the population
and people have gotten it whether they
were vaccinated or not
they start to see the reality of what
the actual risk was
um you know Burns through their entire
family their parents get it they might
even be have some comorbidities they
might be 80 years old or whatever and
they did fine I mean so you have enough
people like that that even though they
sort of bought the story on the idea of
um
sort of distorted risk that everybody
had the reality of being infected and
having that direct exposure lessened the
fear and the willingness to go along
but I think you know so I mean if some
if some pandemic happened right now I
think there'd be a lot of pushback
because we're so close to what happened
with the covid-19 pandemic but I do
think that there is going to be you know
an official story that has to be more
correct than Incorrect and I think
that's a that's going to be a fight
that's going to go on for a while so
well so part of what you've concluded
actually is somewhat optimistic and
because your conclusion seems to be that
once the facts of the severity of the
illness were actually
thoroughly and and tangibly
accessible because so many people ended
up with kovid they weren't hypothesizing
it anymore that we had enough grounding
in our civil rights tradition
to return to
to normality right so once the fear did
decrease
to a somewhat normal level
we didn't find the attractions of the
authoritarian lockdown sufficient to
continue in that direction so there is
some optimism in that
right they reverted we reverted back to
being a free society that there is I
mean but you still see hints of things
that um
are sort of left over like drives to you
know I've read articles about you know
eliminating there's been several of them
like this eliminating
um all respiratory viruses from the air
of buildings based on their ventilation
and filtering and engine building
engineering basically
and uh you know I mean one one thing we
one thing we witnessed when kids had
finally been
um in in-person schools is that they
were getting lots of viruses I mean um
influenza adenovirus RSV these things
spiked and sometimes it was even in the
summer outside of their normal Seasons
because these endemic viruses had been
suppressed
and uh it were it actually the
separation and distancing worked better
for those endemic viruses
than they did for the pandemic virus
itself
and so the idea of you know eliminating
respiratory viruses from the air that we
breathe I think is uh is not right I
think it's a dangerous idea and uh um
much like people who fought when
antibiotics came out that you could just
give everybody an antibiotic and for
anything
um
that there would be no downside to that
now of course we know that there is so I
think there is a lot of of sort of
hubris that's still out there about
um you know eliminating risk even from
sort of every day infections that I
think is is going to take a while to
to go away yes well the part part of the
hubris is that we don't understand that
the demand to risk to reduce risk to
zero is as Cardinal form of risk right
because it requires a kind of impossible
totalitarian overreach it's probably the
case when we're agitating for zero
anything you know because I think the
same thing with regard to the War on
Drugs I think the same thing with
regards to Net Zero on the climate front
it's like no you're mitigating one form
of risk but you're radically
increasing another form of risk and it's
obvious that that's what we did with the
pandemic is there anything else you want
to bring to the attention of our viewers
and listeners before we close out we've
been talking I'll just let everybody
know we've been talking to Steve
Templeton today about his book fear of a
microbial Planet how a germaphobic
safety culture makes us less safe and so
you can obviously pick up that book and
walk through Steve's argument in more
detail is there anything else that you
think people should know that we haven't
covered or are we at a point where we
can reasonably begin to bring this to a
close
yeah I mean I think uh you know just uh
when you ask something about how do you
respond to this how do you how do you
fix things
um that's obviously a very difficult
question
but you know some of the things that
we've lost in the previous
three years
um you know like our communities
um
our education of our children
the ability to sort of challenge them
which has gone on for much longer in
terms of a safety culture
I mean it's important to try to try to
reverse some of that and I think that uh
that could go a long way
um to to making things better
right yeah well it's a difficult
as we said earlier we don't understand
the preconditions all the preconditions
that were in place to allow children to
roam and range more freely than they do
now and so it's very difficult to figure
out what we would have to
return to let's say or approach in order
for that to
to occur again I mean to some degree
encouraging parents to understand that
fostering Independence in their kids is
the mo is the proper risk-free approach
I mean people can learn and I wrote
about that a fair bit in my especially
in my book 12 rules for life
um encouraging parents to understand
that
they can be the biggest risk to their
children because of their hyper concern
with safety absolutely and that's the
message is that you know this
paradoxical
um safety culture makes actually
children less safe less prepared
to face the world and was prepared to
deal with any sort of threat whether
it's microbial or you know arguments in
college with people they disagree with I
mean a lot of these things are are
related yeah yeah well it's it's always
one risk or another it's never no risk
absolutely so and that is a hard yeah
yeah exactly exactly all right well for
everyone watching and listening
on YouTube and Associated platforms
thank you very much for your time and
attention
to Dr Steve Templeton author of fear of
a microbial Planet thank you very much
for talking to me today we're going to
go over to the Daily wire plus platform
now I'm going to talk to Steve for an
additional half an hour about the
development of his interest in
Immunology
and uh if you'd like to join us there
that would be just fine otherwise thank
you very much Dr Templeton it's been a
pleasure talking to you and uh thank you
for the book and congratulations on its
success and hopefully the message that
you're attempting to distribute will be
picked up and there'll be some positive
consequence of that thank you it's been
an honor to chat with you
hello everyone I would encourage you to
continue listening to my conversation
with my guest on dailywireplus.com